Would you say it has not been fantastic?
It has not been marvelous.
Or fantastic.
Or amazing, or spiderman.
I'm here with Tom and Nina to talk about which
actors and actresses we most want to join
the MCU.
Nina, which actors and actresses do you most
want to join the MCU?
Well, one of these was just gifted to me a
couple of days ago because you know, Julia
Louis Dreyfus just recently joined the MCU,
and as many people know she was the star of
many TV shows, but most recently and notably
she starred on Veep.
And one of her co-stars, Sam Richardson, said
that he wants to play Beast in the MCU because
he thinks that Beast is his Veep character,
Richard Split, but huge and with blue hair.
Oh, that rocks.
And I love Sam Richardson.
He's great on Veep.
If you're not familiar with him, you're really
missing out on him.
He's also...he works with Tim Robinson a lot
and was on my favorite show of my life, I
Think You Should Leave.
And they work together on Detroiters.
I would love to see Sam Richardson join the
MCU.
And that got me thinking of like other comedians.
I think Ben Schwartz would be really funny
in the MCU, but I don't know where he would
go.
Like improvisers, like Lauren Lapkus would
be really funny as well.
Yeah.
I was just thinking about like, the MCU is
known for being funny, right?
I mean, James Gunn and take away Taika Waititi
especially like have very distinct senses
of humor, and that really shines through in
their movies.
And then I was also like, wouldn't it be weird
if like Timothee Chalamet just popped up at
the MCU as like a really like emo teen alien.
I wouldn't say no to...
Who could he be?
Who could Timothee Chalamet play?
I was thinking about like, you know, Florence
Pugh just joined, and she was in Little Women
with Timothee Chalamet and Saoirse Ronan,
and I'm like, hmm, Laura Dern?
Let's throw her in the mix too.
I don't think Timothee Chalamet could play
Laura Dern.
I don't think he has the range for it.
Well I mean, that's fair.
No one can play Laura Dern except for Laura
Dern.
That's right.
But yeah I mean, I know I was just all over
the map with that, but you know, obviously
more comedians is never going to hurt.
Sam Richardson definitely should play Beast.
I hope he already got the offer to be honest
with you.
But yeah.
I mean, let's let some of these prestige actors
like Laura Dern or Timothee Chalamet have
a little fun.
Okay.
I like it.
I've never heard anybody say that more comedians
couldn't hurt before.
But maybe that's just the air in the wind.
I think you've just been doing standup for
too long Tom.
I haven't been doing standup for not long
enough.
So...
Tom, what are some of the actors and actresses
you want to see added to the MCU?
First off it seems like a crime that Rowan
Atkinson hasn't been a part of this yet.
Oh, good one.
Rowan Atkinson.
Thank you very much.
I mean, number one, I don't think that we've
seen enough straight white men in the MCU,
and I that he could really fill a vacuum there.
Right.
Also just the...no, that those seem weird,
right?
Like that seems like an easy paycheck that
he could've picked up.
For Rowan Atkinson?
Yeah, he doesn't have to be a main character.
It's just like, he's a background Nova Corps,
like standing up too straight and not approving
of these Guardians of the Galaxy.
Something like that.
He could do something kind of like...I mean,
I never enjoy bringing up Love Actually personally,
but in that movie, he just kind of floats
around on the fringe and like interacts with
different characters and it's the best part
of the movie.
Totally.
You know, yeah.
He could do something like that in the MCU
and I would be on board.
I'm down for it.
Yeah.
He could just come back as the same character
he played in The Tall Guy.
So yeah, that'd be...right now, I'm just bonkers
for HBO adaptation of Doom Patrol that they're
doing.
If they wanted to bring the entire cast of
that show into play, like, their analog X-men
characters, I think...
That's an interesting thought.
I like that.
I'd watch it.
Yeah.
Yeah, no problem.
So Brendan Fraser would be who?
Who's the analog to Robotman?
It's got to be Wolverine, right?
You bring him in as like the angry break stuff
guy.
Oh, yeah.
Is he Canadian?
I think he's Canadian, is he?
He is Canadian.
So it wouldn't even be appropriation, and
he's...yeah.
No, he's got his memory all dicked with, so
yeah.
No that's Wolverine.
So that works.
Yeah.
That'd be cool.
I mean, I'm never against watching Timothee...
Chalamet.
I'm for it.
Yeah, Timothee Chalamet.
Justice for Timothee Chalamet.
Sorry, what were you going to say?
He'll be part of Doom Patrol.
No, I've been watching the version of Doom
Patrol where Timothee Chalamet just live-streams
himself watching it too, like, eating handfuls
of Oreos.
I mean, now that we're on the subject of Doom
Patrol, Alan Tudyk, right?
Is that how you say his name?
Alan Tudyk.
How has he not been in the MCU yet?
I think he does a lot of work for Disney too.
And he's good.
And isn't he actually starring on a TV show
right now where he plays an alien in human
form?
He's starring in 80 TV shows and he's in like
every cartoon version of a superhero thing.
He's the greatest.
He's played the Green Arrow, he's played the
Joker, he's played Arcade.
Yeah, no.
This is wonky.
Do you think we could get him and Gina Torres
in there together somehow?
I feel relatively positive...
Have a little tiny Firefly reunion?
With every surviving member of Firefly?
Yeah.
No big deal.
We've already got Nathan Fillion, he's got
two different parts...
I was going to say, Nathan Fillion just popped
up in.
But that's Suicide Squad, right?
Nathan Fillion was going to be Wonder Man
in movie posters as an easter egg.
I think that all got cut.
But he has like cameos in the Guardians movies,
cause I think he's friends with James Gunn.
He is friends with James Gunn.
Was he in the Guardian's movies?
He's a prisoner in the jail.
He's the one who threatens Peter, and then
Groot sticks his fingers up his nose and just
decimates him.
That's Nathan voice.
That's Nathan Fillion?
Yeah.
It's just his voice.
I don't know if he did any motion capture
work for it, but it is his voice.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
He was like back in the days friends with
James Gunn.
Because he did Slither but he also did PG
Porn.
Yeah, exactly.
Wow.
Hilarious.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, that's a funny video.
Yeah.
Nathan Fillion.
Tiny little MCU cameo dude.
That does seem like the easiest possible,
like, nerd cred thing that we could do, right?
Is just get the entire cast of Firefly back
together.
Just bring everyone back now that Joss Whedon
is out of the picture.
Just bring...just make Firefly part of the
MCU.
Oh, don't make it weird.
Yeah.
Just make Firefly MCU Canon.
I mean Disney owns it now, right?
Yeah.
It's Fox.
Bring it back.
Anyway, we've gotten off topic.
So for me, the two actors that I...I wrote
a few different actors down that I really
like.
But the two that I was happiest about, I also
got their roles in mind.
And it's Richard Ayoade, from The IT Crowd.
Love him.
Cool.
I want him to play Mr. Fantastic in the Fantastic
Four movie.
Interesting.
And America Ferrera, from Superstore.
And I want her to be the Invisible Woman.
And I want to see what they're like, because
Richard Ayoade is very good at being intelligent
and aloof and funny and charming all at the
same time.
And America Ferrera is good at being tough
and caring and powerful and bringing a bunch
of weirdos together to get stuff done, from
Superstore.
Great show.
So I just think that if you stick those two
together, you bring life to these two parts
that in the past, again, the previous Fantastic
Four movies...there's some good stuff, there's
some not so good stuff.
But overall I would say that the dynamic between
Mr and Ms Fantastic has not necessarily been
all that interesting or exciting.
Would you say it has not been fantastic?
It has not been marvelous, or fantastic, or
amazing, or spiderman.
But I think that...and I'm not necessarily
saying that these two actors have like such
great chemistry.
I have no idea.
But they're interesting choices.
They're choices that I don't think I ever
would've thought of if I hadn't been asked
this question, and I think I would love to
see something...everyone talks about John
Krasinski and Emily blunt as the two leads
of the Fantastic Four.
And it's like, sure. Why not. Fine. Okay.
Yeah. I mean that would work.
Yeah. It's fine.
Like they're great. If they got cast tomorrow, I'd be like yeah.
Cool, okay. I'll see that movie.
I actually just watced Quiet Place for the
first time this weekend, Because I am really
easily frightened.
So, that was not something I went into lightly.
They're very good at it.
Like, they're great actors and they work beautifully
together, obviously.
So yeah, I'd be psyched, but let's go for
maybe a less obvious choice.
Let's just try something a little different.
And plus, Emily Blunt recently, at least at
the time at the time of this recording, recently
was like, "stop asking me about it.
Kind of sick of hearing about it.
I don't think I'm going to do it."
So I'm kind of like, all right, cool.
So let's find and talk about someone else.
So let's make this happen.
Like Richard Ayoade and America Ferrara.
Why not?
They're very...
Really talented people.
And you were like "I don't know if they'd
work well together", but here's why I think
they might, is they're both trained comedic
actors who have worked with...their resumes
are very ensemble based.
I mean, American Ferrera did the Sisterhood
of the Traveling Pants movie, she did Ugly
Betty, she did Superstore.
Richard Ayoade has done...the IT Crowd is
very much based on riffing off one another
and the chemistry, right?
So they're both people with experience in
working with ensembles and making that work.
So I think they could be great together.
And Richard Ayoade has already worked with
Disney in the Star Wars universe doing the
voice of that robot, from Mandalorian.
The one whose name we all remember.
It's a bunch of numbers and letters.
It's numbers.
That's fine.
And then he was also in Soul.
Everybody's name is a bunch of numbers and
letters.
He was in Soul.
I forgot he was in Soul.
I think overall at the very least, I really...I'm
excited about that idea.
I'm like...in my head now it's already happening.
But it's just kind of like, what would that
be like?
And he could keep his British accent.
I don't want to hear him doing an American
accent.
Make him British, who cares?
Just go with it.
It'd be interesting.
Brian, can I ask you who would play Ben Grimm
in your version?
I didn't think that far ahead, but I do think
you could just get Michael Chiklis back.
Can I make the recommendation?
Sure.
Rowan Atkinson.
Perfect.
Who's going to play the human torch?
Probably also Rowan Atkinson.
He's got a lot of...
Rowan Atkinson is a good choice.
He contains multitudes.
Yeah.
You know who could be a really good thing?
Jesse Plemons.
Oh.
Yeah.
He's a bigger dude.
He's not known for his small stature.
He's a big presence, and he's got...he's an
incredible actor.
He's super good at everything he does.
True.
You know, like Game Night is a movie I really
liked.
Oh I loved Game Night.
One of the best like blockbuster mainstream
comedies that has been made.
Like a mainstream comedy that's legitimately
funny.
He's so funny in that movie.
He's so good in that.
And he was also in I'm Thinking of Ending
Things, and he was also in Fargo season two,
and these are all things I think he was great
in.
He was in the Star Trek episode of Black Mirror,
USS Callister, which is terrifying.
He's really good in it.
Yeah.
So there you go.
So, go ahead.
No, I just had an idea...nah.
You know what, we don't have to talk about
it, but I did just have an idea.
Vincent D'Onofrio.
Get Vincent D'Onofrio in to play Ben Grimm.
I think that that would rock.
But he was already the Kingpin.
Yeah.
I mean, that's true, I guess.
But who cares?
Because they've already got Copperhead back
to be Blades, so they're...
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So who's Human Torch?
Besides Rowan Atkinson.
Second choice.
I have no idea.
I refuse to even...I'm not going to entertain
this.
Timothee Chalamet.
Laura Dern.
We've done it.
There it is.
Zoom in on Tom's eyes.
Thanks for joining us.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single new episode.